hello and welcome to this video playing
soptic
26. yeah um
in the game before if you watch them
in a in a row let's say or the three
videos per day in one batch then i only
looked at the end game of that game
and now it turns out i could have just
won a piece
after six or seven moves so um i did not
look at this in the video i just looked
at the end game
i thought well what happened before it's
not really all that relevant
but um the game should have been over
after six or seven moves whatever it was
crazy um anyway
so let's have a look
at this game um yeah
this is a problem i'm currently
writing chapters on this opening the
fianchetto king's indian
i'm not there yet i'm currently looking
at study material like
onions and stuff and uh
yeah this that would be a moment where
uh
yeah where cheating is eminent yeah
looking at all those books
beside me but of course i cannot do that
and i'm not yet
knowledgeable so i know that this is a
line but i don't know any details
so let's see um
he's attacking e4 twice i still have it
covered
as often counterplay here against
my against the pawn
knight b3 queen before i wonder
there are lines where you can
sacrifice the pawn and get these six in
return i don't think
this is one of them
can i do that
for before knight e5 might be on
i don't know it's a bit awkward to
invent this
now during the game you should
absolutely know it
there's also some queen e2 i think in
lines
[Music]
okay knight b3 now he has to go back
and i could go to d2 well that's
probably not
best oh there might be queen a6 actually
no didn't do it okay um
c5 is generally desirable in such a
position
there's knight c4 however
knight d2 is a little bit on the passive
side but
it's a pragmatic solution for the moment
simply cover that pawn
bishop e6 maybe
yeah i'm in that stage where i'm writing
a new repertoire
and the fianchetto king's indian is new
in my in my games
i have never played that seriously in
in classical time controls not even in
blitz
so some lines i already do know quite
well
because i have already finished the
writing
and in some cases i'm
only playing it by ear so to say i i
know
kind of how things should work but i
don't know
any details and this is one of those
lines
okay um but i think that it looks like
he's also not
like dashing out moves quickly knowing
everything
now f4 is usually
good yeah let's do that f4
and b4 yeah don't
don't see why not
maybe has some d5 stuff
okay maybe i should have taken the time
to prepare that like rook b1 or so
because there's always the danger
of overexpansion in such a situation i
have
a huge space advantage but
sometimes there are there are vulnerable
spots
like g3 is not protected
b4 is not protected after the capture
the diagonal could be tender so the
the danger is um that you kind of
have us have a slightly fragile position
in some way
okay um because you have taken so much
space
okay c5 is what you want to play the
question is
can you play it is there a tactic or
you can still think about playing the
rook but he can take and play
rook a3 then okay let's play the move
that
looks like the most desirable
oh i did not
see that coming
if i take e3 is hanging this is what i
meant there it's kind of loose
yeah one more prep move probably would
have been better
because exposition was absolutely
horrifically bad
if i prepare that it's just absolutely
clear
now maybe there's yeah stuff like that
and black is in the game
this is the problem the whole position
the whole kind of structure for black is
just awful
but you kind of have to pay attention to
not
fall into trickery like this and then
now my position is just falling apart
yeah yeah one more prep move and this is
always a joke the whole thing
awful it's just
absolutely awful
i don't want to resign
but i'm down everything
yeah the the i mean i told you
the danger but i didn't didn't really
act on it
and the position was so good that you
can afford all the time in the world i
mean
what is black supposed to do with this
no space
no idea position
yeah come on that is pointless now this
this is making me sick
it's like this is just like this
position is winning
it's just a winning position and well
you can switch it on this is like
now on 1.5 maybe plus two
yeah it's just um if you just do it
right it's just
basically over because black is stuck on
three ranks and cannot move
you just have to be a little bit more
cautious
i even overlooked d5 in the first place
i was just like
whatever yeah and after d5 it's awkward
and i should probably just think a
little bit about this
and find queen d3 to not lose
immediately it's pretty awkward looking
move but
at least you continue the game after
e595 i'm lost
so you just play the rook here and
then black is stuck in this awful
position
yeah with the problem here if you look
at black's position
they cannot move a single pawn ever yeah
you can what the engine is giving here
is kind of just be a little bit annoying
and then retreat everything
um but you cannot actively
improve your position with black that's
just not possible
you can never move the b pawn the c ball
and the d pawn nothing
and i'm just going to expand in this
position and
what is black supposed to do you only as
as we have witnessed first hand have to
be careful with that expansion and i
totally failed on that task
so what is good here for example
you have a couple of moves that you can
play like king h2
for example to be a little bit more safe
the immediate c5 might still be a little
bit tricky
due to yeah exactly taking on queen a5
and this is
still a little bit of a problem this
would be
excellent if i manage e5 knight e5 96
that is the strategic idea of this
but interestingly the engine wants to do
this
that's kind of funny that is just a
repetition right
so that cannot be a solution
but you can definitely play different
moves here you have to just um
do it right this looks good actually
that's a good move
make sure that the knight is not ever
going here for example to b6
and it prepares c5 what you see here in
the line
knight hf8 c5
this is the strategic um
yeah goal that white is aiming for if
you
manage that and ultimately e5 knight e4
then black is falling apart
so what i got here was essentially the
kind of
model position that you want out of this
opening but it also showed
the model way of yeah playing it in the
wrong way
c5 is just premature
and then black was um yeah right on
point in in doing that and now
you see the looseness of my position
here with g3 e3 c3 so
this is the danger of this expansion and
you have to make sure that
that all that space that you have gained
is really
secured and um this is kind of
interesting
to compare to actually a strategy
in in in in wars yeah classic
um land wars like in the in the
um times of let's say napoleon or or
later even in the first or second world
war when you gain
huge amounts of territory you have to
kind of defend that so otherwise
the enemy might get like into your
territory and it's not really um
appropriately secured and this is kind
of an interesting comparison
so here i should definitely be more
circumspect and not play
c5 i kind of did that on general grounds
and did not
if i would have just taken a moment to
see that d5 as possible
of course i would immediately reject the
move but
i did not um it did not register
and seeing that this is unprotected
should have been the pointer to that
just register that this is unprotected
it's actually the
most problematic piece because
everything else is at least
protected once if it comes to pieces but
on that one
okay guys thanks for watching